[Music]
you're on the side here yeah but look
there's no hand fighting that sucks yeah
okay okay
you could maybe drop and turn but not
really man I'm [__] there with your
head in here that already hurts your
arms aren't even in there the arms
aren't in there no he's like yes yeah
now try and get your arms in okay I
can't yeah ah you could drop and turn
okay but stop because I broke
damn that sucks oh you're crying no
because you and Holly Holmes have the
same ass no what I would do this here is
so if you have so here's what I want to
teach people
you have a gun okay in your hand a big
box
don't do that just hold on to the gun oh
yeah all right the minute you have the
gun okay guns from the Holly Holm choke
no because say I'm teaching people how
to defend it it's just special so you're
here and you're you're holding up the
place all right
I'm gonna do this I'm gonna jump up
hold on
now now look now you I had this pinned
okay sorry but I can still hold on I'm
gonna shoot your foot
but take the pain lose your foot you
don't lose your foot because you're
going to see your foot
hold my feet ah okay but you don't know
what Jiu Jitsu but I had my I had that
there you you can't guard your throat if
I if I grab your I'm gonna shut your
foot dude huh and broke your ankles yeah
but I would grab the other I would grab
the other arm
so really what I would do is this I
would go like this down so you're like
yeah I'd go like this yeah I'd go I go
a man looks you can't look when you're
on another man's shoulder you can't as a
man I look there's no way to make this
book straight this is chicken fighting
but I'm land this is chicken fighting
but I'm late
wow
all right see God
that's good man all right that was good
good technique
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
you know dude I like sports and I like
money and uh I don't know how to get
both I know because you're a baseball
expert like I'm covering this well you
don't move my mind around athletes
athlete you love baseball he's an
all-around athlete I also love money
dude but do you love MLB right you love
me you know you can bet on a fight night
fight night London low two Arenas this
Saturday you can watch that aspinel's
fighting what do I do I gotta go to
Vegas and buy some chips no dude you can
just download DraftKings and use promo
code fighter that's right take your shot
at huge wins with draftking Sportsbook
you could win big with money lines props
parlays and more talking about MLB's hot
right now UFC's pop and daddy right now
new customers can score 150 in bonus
bets instantly for betting just five
dollar rules on anything MLB UFC
whatever you want download the
DraftKings Sportsbook app and use code
fighter that's code fighter only at
draftking Sportsbook Cameron probably
called 100 again with New York called
8778 hope NY on text help NY 467-369 in
West Virginia visit
www.1800 gambler.net in partnership with
Hollywood Casino at Charlestown Races
all games regulated by the West Virginia
Lottery please pay responsibly in
Connecticut is available for problem
gambling
888-789-777 or visit
ccpg.org on behalf of Boot Hill Casino
and Resorts Kansas 21 and over in most
eligible States but age varies by
jurisdictions if draftkings.com
Sportsbook for details and say
specifically responsible gambling
resources bonus bets expire seven days
after issuance eligibility and deposit
restrictions apply terms of Sportsbook
dot draftkings.com baseball terms terms
of Sportsbook dot draftkings.com
baseball terms uh guys I want to first
of all I'm a little out of breath right
now and not because me and Brandon were
wrestling and not because Brandon
complimented my ass by comparing it to
Holly Holmes you jumped on me like a
Spiderman he's got a fantastic lower
body and when somebody Compares my body
to that body I got aroused and jumped me
dude I jumped you but I'm more out of
breath because you you're talking about
you just described a porn scene that got
me all kinds of hot and bothered I don't
approve see it's possible to not approve
of a porn scene not impossible is not a
proof of a situation and still get hot
and bothered that's a devil talking yeah
that's the devil and sometimes the devil
is somebody you got to learn how to
ignore yeah I don't want to backstory to
my pornos like I don't need a no no I
don't need MTV's on no plot no no no no
no no no no no I fast forward through
this highlight reel ladies and gentlemen
yeah just just give me the nitty-gritty
that's right now what gets you going is
it big Cannon number one big cannon need
a big Cannon and yours just so you can
see what a liar your girl is you're like
oh you're at acting like my can my my
piece yeah is gonna do the same thing
that that Canon's gonna do but I happen
to know that that Canon is well there
are professionals you know what there
are guys that are like there are pro
athletes they're a professional that's
what they do and I ain't one of them no
and that's the truth and that's okay but
I don't watch the NBA and go I'm similar
like when I watched our boy put it down
I'm like he he just has a talent it's
this guy given talent I was given a
compliment and now I'm a straight man
but unless there's a big old cannon I
like it well I had I had I like it I was
giving accomplish it was two females
their scissoring does nothing for me
nothing nothing at all I might as well I
might as well watch planet Earth I'll go
right if it's two females i i dude I
will pass that so fast I know some guys
are into it
dude if there's not a wiener involved
here's what I need here's what I need it
I need right I need a guy who's got a
better body than me preferably darker
skin a much bigger Cannon tattoos and a
girl who you know uh probably is similar
to what my girl looks like so I can feel
bad about myself but no no no I don't
like to watch ones that look like my
girl oh really no and there's a lot that
look like my girl yeah like in the porn
world big ass big titties small waist I
like to mix it up okay okay I like to
mix it up dude I like to mix it up I I
like the the male female yin yang thing
dots too gotta have that that's number
one I had a compliment from an old girl
a female on female no I got have you
ever had a compliment from an old
girlfriend where you went
I was talking to an old old girlfriend
old girlfriend she reached out to you
ran by accident uh talking about her her
kid her son oh you rant her at that
friend talk we had a great talk
and she said uh
something to the effect of
you uh she complimented my my uh Decay
no my my coitus skills your what my my
uh my uh tongue my tongue skills oh what
that what that now go down yeah she said
she said uh nobody better and she said
and you would make me laugh a lot we're
all doing it and I said I said well that
means you laugh and come a lot she goes
yeah so of course I liked you yeah and I
went and that's a joke I make that's a
joke I have in my standout and I was
like you know what she goes so it made
total sense and then I looked at her and
I volunteer I go my dick game isn't bad
she goes not at all but it but she
didn't I had to she said she had better
I could have let it go she had better
there you go she had better well we're
comfortable bring it up aggressive
you're at like Ralphs and she went what
that mouth do daddy you went well Amy so
good this is very funny you said it
because it was in the it was in Home
Depot aisle oh even Saturn yeah
right hey hey
Home Depot
oh I don't know anything no you know
nothing Oh you mean hey oh because I
kind of know my name is a little bit but
I know nothing I I I'm a little bit of a
handyman you if you said to me go get a
washer for the sink I'd be like oh you
know what you're doing all right dude
that is dude Home Depot for the real bro
the real dude my father-in-law that's
some daddies my ex-wife my father-in-law
knew how to fix everything yeah I went
to Home Depot one time and he goes go
ahead and get one of the washers and
we'll get uh get a thing and I'm like
and he goes you don't know what that is
do you I go I don't oh when you walk to
Home Depot you might as well have a
rainbow across your chest it's not for
you and I said I fake my I fake I fake
my way in Home Depot my excuse I go I
grew up overseas he goes no you grew up
rich like I know I didn't have that much
she had enough money so you I we
couldn't call anybody yes yeah that's
what you had money yeah my dad took me a
place called Builder Square
and it was just like Home Depot but like
the mom and pop shop so we'd go there
every weekend so I know my way around a
little bit my father-in-law Mr Handyman
yeah we walk in there I don't think I'm
gay so I'll go oh you get the paint
buckets and I'll go find the the washers
and and I just asked somebody
I'm not gonna tell them I don't know
where it's at because you have an apron
sir I don't know anything
um
I I uh my father my father grew up with
no money and he grew up having to do all
that [__] so now my dad if you ask him
to do I mean anything bro if you say can
you screw in that light bulb for real he
won't do it because it reminds everyone
he was really poor so he has it he has
an emotional block my mother goes I
can't get him to screw in a light bulb
because it reminds him when he had he
had to work construction back in the day
he had to do he had he was a jackhammer
guy because he was bigger yeah so he had
to do that real manual refused to do it
he won't do anything you love having to
do it he's like no no I'll pay you
[__] I'll pay you yeah instead
of having to do all my lawn yeah
dude I went to uh Knott's Berry Farm
with the fam this weekend just on just
on a whim we had Sunday you won't be
stuck in the house all day with the
kiddos these kids are nuts a lot of wine
so we gotta get that no
that's a Knott's Berry might be the best
part because it's not woke Disney and
it's not packed like Disney's so packed
it's an annoying now it's so expensive
unless you do VIP which is it costs all
the dollars each person be no 500 that's
hilarious yeah I know for the Fastpass
it's a nightmare so Disney's bit of
nightmare on their woke so I stay away
from it Universal's packed because they
have Mario World and you know their VIP
is pretty expensive but then uh great
dad oh dude dude here's why you fell in
love with Joanna and here's why Joanna
is my favorite
nope that was before that was uh that
was always one of the stuff that's the
thing that caught my attention wow just
be clear here that's actually not why
you fell in love with it no there's tons
of that I remember what happened
she when she saw my children my my wife
at the time said look at how she looks
at these kids look at the way she look
at how she's so connected to those kids
and I said to you look that woman that's
that's that's Wifey right there yeah
look at how great she is with the kids
and she had class yeah yeah real class
you know I know that really makes it
less classy but um look at Boston I
don't know why he's throwing up the hang
loose but that's new for him oh look at
that too he's all with this shirt he's
three how well do they get along oh dude
I mean I admire them like they get along
they they share a room together is your
son 18 or 19 how old is he he's 22 he's
Dominican he's got hair on his good at
baseball 100 Dominican yeah I think yeah
but so they want to you know they want
the toys there and stuff and I always go
wait to the end wait to the end and
they're walking through and some guy
recognized me he goes he goes come on
job come you crush this game I was like
I'm always pretty good at carnival games
it's the one where he hit he go you just
gotta get over 100 and you can win any
toy I said well I'm gonna need two he
goes get over 100 you get you you can
get it dude I cry I hit 140 the first
time and 122 the second you did boom you
got hit right in the middle got those
two damn toys I said yeah you're still a
piece of [__] dude boom yeah that's
better but you're a [__] you know you
annoy the [__] out of me cause I'm Bam
Bam no cause you're not no because you
didn't do it right
you could have done better yeah you know
you know what the problem man no but you
know what the promise you gotta go you
go there you go there yeah no toys for
the kids oh I know listen I go there I
go there they go you can't come back
leverage bro you know you know how like
Danny can't gamble in Vegas yeah I can't
play games at carnival
non-blackball dudes for reals they went
do not come back but they said you can
play the rides you can't play the
carnival game I need
you did it the last one you you slide
your hand down so you get more torque
and then bring it down I don't need to
do that that's for you simple tins and I
just went cool Bam Bam give me the toy
and I need one for the younger one get
that give me the toy I said oh that's a
basketball and the Rim's small and the
ball's bigger say less swish next no you
don't have touch swish you don't have to
touch hit the first one I know you
that's how we won the third game
baseball let me see that ball thing
going shank like a otanic no I throw as
fast as you and heart and you know that
right because we played dodgeball
remember hey you go to Carnival yeah you
go to Carnival Kids get no toys sad day
for Dad right
you don't know his way around Home Depot
done on your way around Home Depot right
true you don't know sports right no I
have nothing pretend no fighting they
know the sports I watched quarterback on
Netflix I know we'll talk about that
yeah uh ohtani what do you think of this
whole situation just playing baseball
right he's gonna say the best ever right
ohtani yep that kid What ethnicity huh
yeah
it's Japanese
splash of it yeah yeah it's got some
he's got some what position does he play
shortstop no no he used to play it nope
what's he play now yes what's he play
now second base no where which one are
you talking about Otani yeah the the
home run leader Outfield nope gotcha
nope
he's a pitcher dude yeah he dude he
pitches he's the best pitcher in
baseball then he's also the best hitter
what and uh I know this Gusty Baker who
played with Willie Mays Hank Aaron he
goes I've never seen anything like it he
might be the best player ever oh this is
he is Japanese and he's Japanese and
Korean oh I don't know is he I think
he's just Japanese no he's a splash of
Korean I thought right Jim I don't he
might be I think Lee Karima grew up in
China I mean Japan that's that's awesome
how do you not know this Jen uh show
time is he 100 in Japanese he played for
the Japanese team
hold on he might be hold on no he's just
he's Japanese Japanese he's only 29.
and he's that good yeah they think he's
like the best ever do it what and but
here's the thing is the Angels suck
which is weird because they have trout
too the Angels suck and he's gonna be a
free agent at the end of the year he's
getting paid all the money in the world
all the money and he knows his way
around Home Depot you get paid all the
money God in Japan at all right oh dude
he's like a K-pop Star in Japan oh dude
he what he's like because he's good
looking he's tall
yeah and and he uh what makes him so
great just his his well the thing about
there haven't been a guy like him since
Babe Ruth remember Babe Ruth could throw
and then also hit he can do both don't
take that picture though right he looks
ugly there yeah don't leave it don't do
that that's what he's younger yeah don't
be in a corner like that yeah yeah he
needs us to be like oh oh he can't be
leaning yeah that's a corner he does his
PR team yeah just like that just stand
there like that that's fine he looks
stupid there too wow yeah I don't know
man I hear you go he's like yeah there
you go yeah so yeah Hugo Boss got it
there you go yeah there you go but he um
yeah man he's just he's like the Babe
Ruth but current but better better babe
because Bay played against all white
guys so don't count yeah there's no
Dominican Stone junk [__] right right
and he's hitting whatever he wants
whatever hitting all the home runs but
he's here's here's the problem I'll wrap
this up he's gonna be a free agent at
the end of the year he can get paid all
the money so if you're the angels I
don't know when the trading deadline is
going to come soon for the Angels he's
leaving because you guys suck all the
Home Depot [__] he's leaving so you
trade him now and get a bunch of money
and picks or you think you have a shot
and right out through the season and
he's your best player and then you know
he's gone at the end of free agency he
can't sign him so once you just trade
him now so you can get some some value a
great pitcher the best pitcher in the
league and the best hitter in the league
he's he's Babe Ruth but on steroids in
Japanese I'm not saying he's on steroids
so one thing about Japanese is that
their their work ethic and their
practice like the book of five rings no
[__] Samurai [__] yep the samurai Suzuki
was that his name Suzuki the guy who is
a phenomenal made SUVs he had a he had a
room in his house where he would only
practice swing he'd practice his swing
over and over again let's take a little
break let's take a little break dude
because you may not think credit scores
a big deal but if you're dealing with a
low credit score good luck man or no
credit score that could be a big problem
if I would check my credit score and my
credit score goes down because I'm
checking it dude you need to get some
chime dude that's why millions of people
swear by our friends at chime secured
credit Builder Visa credit card credit
Builder is just a better way to build
your credit you know you can't get very
far in life you want a car house with
bad credit you build your credit score
safely with everyday purchases and
on-time payments Plus for an annual fee
no dude no annual fee no matter credit
checks no no no no no no man use it
everywhere Visa cards are accepted
interest or credit checks to apply I can
use it everywhere a Visa credit card is
accepted and I can build credit using my
own money dude get paid up to two days
earlier fee free overdraft with spot me
overdraft up to 200 without fees with
the spot me when you set up and if you
qualify for direct deposit ditch the
monthly fees chime has no monthly
minimum balance or overdraft fees you
have over 60 000 fee free ATMs all right
that's more than the top three National
Banks combine easily find one near you
with the chime app send and receive
money super easy pay your friends family
whatever you got to do your credit's a
big deal so build yours raise friends
through chime no matter what my bank
account it is and it's cash out
and it's got It's for free it's fee free
yeah dude that's a big deal so build
yours up with chime just open a chime
checking account with a 200 plus
qualified direct deposit to get started
get started at chime.com fighter that's
chime.com fighter time credit card
chime credit Builder Visa credit cards
issued by stride Bank NA member FDIC
chime checking account and a 200
qualifying direct deposit required to
apply out of network ATM withdrawals
fees May apply on-time payment history
may have a positive impact on your
credit score late payments May
negatively impact your credit score
results May Vary let's chime.com fighter
chime on there's a second the whole
thing to them you know and uh was that
his name no no I know you're talking
about yeah uh good looking dude
Ichiro dude [__] you throw think about
Master Splinter what he did with five
teenage turtles all right yes anything
what he did with them yes you're right
there he is Ichiro
of all time if he went to the Mariners
that Southwest or the North Pacific dude
because the All-Star game was there his
he had the biggest Applause because
think about so much Asian out there if
you went to the Giants to be set the
rumor is Phillies because Phillies have
the most like money and draft picks and
so how does he a guy like that you know
it's interesting to me the biggest
contractor because he knows how to
manage that that pressure too right so
he's Japanese
yeah that's a huge part like the
difference in getting there and staying
there is you know some guys have trouble
staying there yeah like they choke in
the regular in the in the playoffs no
he's a baller wasn't that the knock on
uh Alex Rodriguez no Alex was good no
I'm not he compared to Derek Jeter was
the problem yeah because they said that
during this
and that's where you get your values
like the guy like in Charles Barkley
talked to us in Shaq he's saying they
they always they should wait to give MVP
to the end of the year don't do in
regular season because if you're a key
player your number should go up 5 10 15
points when you get to the playoffs
because that's when it counts that's
when the team needs you more yeah that's
when they look Kobe would go off Shaq
would go off bar all the greats get
better when the pressure's on that's
crazy and then some guys don't like Kyle
Murray who won uh comeback player of the
year the ESPYs shout out to Pat McAfee
crush it hosting it but uh uh Murray won
Jamal sorry Jamal Murray won to come
back play of the year for the nuggets
he he's decent in the regular season
playoffs came and he he's a superstar
that's what you want that's why you pay
those guys yes he just steps up
yeah but this can be interested to see
what happens to Otani all I watch is
baseball now because my son all we watch
is I like quarterback was really cool I
told you to watch quarterback you don't
understand because how great the the key
that I want you to see Peyton Mann's an
executive producer on it and he goes I
might be biased but quarterback is the
toughest position all professional
sports I agree with that because the
ball you hit the ball every single play
the focus is on you every single play
Target on your back the number of reads
you have to make just before the snap
after the snap no it's insane it's not
only is it insane but like watching what
I think that the secret to
um
uh Kansas City Chiefs uh Patrick Mahomes
uh thing is of course athleticism and
free stuff but he's loving he loves the
game he's it's almost like it's a game
to him he's playing pickup you know
baseball was his thing he's a baseball
guy and Alex Rodriguez his Godfather and
Alex when he was in high school goes go
in the draft he got drafted he was going
the draft forget football and now Alex
goes thank God you're gonna listen to me
I think he's the best to ever do it even
now yeah we've never seen anything like
it here's my caveat with that so it
follows three quarterbacks it follows
um Patrick Holmes Patrick Mahomes it
follows the Marcus Marietta uh Marriott
up for the Atlanta Falcons then it
follows homeboy the white nerdy guy who
actually loves so nerdy but so annoying
so it's a regular guy and like really
sentimental he had a great quote because
he gets a lot of hate what's his name
he's for on the Vikings quarterback for
the Vikings um starter cousins Kirk
Cousins so he he's the opposite of the
he's the opposite of the of like Patrick
Mahones he's not showy but he just wins
and so he's at Minnesota they're damn
good last year but he gets a lot of hate
and then no one ever puts him in the top
ten but he always puts up numbers and he
goes my grandma he said the best thing
to me she goes uh I they could see me
walk on water and they'd say it's
because he can't walk that's a Margaret
that Margaret Thatcher said uh she was
the premiere of England she said uh I
could be well I might I could walk on
water and my haters would say it's
because I can't swim yeah and that yeah
it's a great quote I'm gonna steal that
now
yeah yeah but he said that he's like
it's a great quote from her and that's
that's the way he deals and he's on
social media and stuff he drives a van
so you know
Margaret Thatcher was the conservative
Prime Minister of England yes when
England had a long run of liberal uh uh
the labor party had taken over and then
Tories took over and she was the Prime
Minister and they said she put the grape
back in Great Britain yep she brought
the economy back and everything yep but
uh Ronald Reagan of England word but
yeah so Kirk it's just a it's a real
difference and I I would say this I
Pastor Holmes comes off as kind of like
a frat bro a little bit he calls his mom
bro
I think that part is it's a game done
but everything's well bra This and like
even his trash talk I sometimes I don't
want to see all that now it's made me
more of a fan of Kirk Cousins even
though we're complete opposite he
doesn't like fashion on a car shoot all
he cares about is football like his wife
dressed some of these nerdy Eddie Bauer
outfits yes thinking about flying [__]
about anything just just he's such a
good family man so I love I'm that show
made me more of a fan of his with
Patrick Holmes I'm like yeah I still
love him but it didn't make me but
something that's really interesting is
that uh David Foster Wallace wrote a
book wrote an essay called he drives
that van bro I know he's incredible
insane is that what's his name uh um uh
David Foster Wallace wrote an essay
called how Tracy Austin broke my heart
Tracy awesome was 14 years old and won
Wimbledon yeah you watched Wimbledon
yesterday she's 14. and then she did an
interview and he was expecting to hear
stuff and he said a lot of times they
did a study on all the physical Geniuses
all the big time winners and when you
see like really big time winners like
someone like Patrick Mahomes part of
what makes them so big and good they
have their black belt in just that yeah
they're not they're not they're not
gonna they they simplify the process so
even when all the heat is on like in
sports science they looked at their
their heart rates and stuff some of the
greatest of all time no matter like
Derek Jeter they were just playing ball
and it didn't matter their heart rate
doesn't go up yeah they keep everything
simple that's why couldn't say they go
you're not worried about like the way
you dressed because it's one less thing
you have to worry about all I care about
is football against God dog damn and
that's and the pressure
the pressure you are it I don't think
anybody can understand that pressure
unless you've been there
quarterback in the NFL 32 position but
isn't it the same in college almost like
isn't it isn't it when you're a starting
quarterback in college in those big
colleges with those stadiums it's crazy
pressure crazy pressure but you're not
playing against the very elite where
yeah like you you saw in that game if
you watched the the second first episode
with Mariota like he fumbles us it's
it's third and one and he fumbles a snap
and they should they were gonna knee and
win the game NFL there's zero room for
error so they go cool get the ball kick
the game win field goal is [__]
that does margin of air so small in NFL
college is a way bigger margin yes you
make mistakes and recover you're such a
good athlete everyone's as as athletic
as you are in the NFL what the one
[__] air you're screwed man
unbelievable it's fascinating isn't it
good yes yes and you'd believe they
don't show back to my home's brother
let's see I accuse that sexual assault
I bet he was more involved than I cut it
cut it cut it he's a [__] dude
talk and he like they have video he
grabs this lady in a bar the owner and
forces tongue down her mouth she like
puts him away and keeps doing it to get
charged with it it'll go away but it's
just a bad look for Patrick Mahomes
his brother really unbelievable that
show's good right yeah he's got and he's
been dating that girl I think he's known
that girl since seventh grade or
something yeah literally yeah fifth
grade I don't know what it is that's a
nice school sweetheart keeping it simple
wife kids at that age I know I know but
it's about football so throw a touchdown
it's not about getting your dick sucked
well
some listen
can you imagine being a young man
in Miami I'm not saying I'm just saying
football but it would be there are some
distractions bathroom Holmes went to
Miami to play the Miami Dolphins thing
but I'm I'm well let me ask you this
um I wonder if um Dan uh
uh who's the quarterback for Miami
forever I'm getting old Dan Marino Dan
Marino he didn't get laid at all bring
up Dan Marino when he was young oh from
Pittsburgh with that with that long hair
he didn't girls in there he had that
afro yeah the girls didn't like him he
wasn't he wasn't bigger than ever
greatest quarterback to never win yeah
his eyes weren't blue and he didn't have
that yeah that's the girls didn't like
uh Tommy Troy Aikman wasn't slanging not
only footballs back in the day been out
of Oklahoma I'm sorry UCLA oh we know
because he got caught with that tweet
when he thought that was a way that was
a while ago but I know you know he's a
dime piece girlfriend
Troy Aikman Troy Aikman was a stud do
you ever see Troy with his shirt off
when he was young you still have no he's
he's Jack he's Jazz he's Jack that's him
right now that just came out two weeks
ago that's him now that's him right now
come on some dimepiece just suck it on
him Suck It Girl a man the hands fingers
this long
spider heads spiders super stun
intense
that's him now
oh look there's a picture of you me on
the beach there we are there we are is
that his dad it's Jimmy Johnson you
piece of [__] yeah one of the greatest
coach of all time
no try again dude still got abs what are
you talking about
I know I'm with you man I said he's a
dime but Jimmy Johnson does it but I
mean Troy Aikman is how old now 50
that's impressive
big Joel big jaw big 56 56 in my age
he's 50. come on
Nikes how about that right that would
make sense he's on my he's from West
Covina I was just there you were just
there Bob I would have done a [__]
tribute to him oh no Troy Aikman's from
West Covina how do they not have a road
named after Troy Aikman how's the laugh
actor in a call Troy Aikman's Laugh
Factory and now he's a single guy two
kids well no he has a girl now this is
does Jordan are they two girls
he's got a girl let me see his girl are
you talking about his daughter or no lay
low for his girlfriend
oh his girlfriend's crashing it she was
in the picture they brought up yeah yeah
we don't look at his kitchen that's
weird I thought he wanted to see his
kids girlfriend nah man read the room
bro all right
what does she do
um decides to take care of that yeah
just it's just generally impossibly hot
yeah but I want to see pictures so I
don't care that much I thought you want
to see what she does no we don't need an
article Instagram's private sale
director cool okay she's a civilian well
look at that there she is great mustache
hahaha
yeah
oh you bet your sweet ass she's gorgeous
yeah it's droikman dude you think he's
hanging out with work quarterbacks
quarterbacks do just fine
he's he's
awesome he's living it dude look at him
he's he looks fantastic oh how jealous
somebody said you look good I don't look
good at all I look like look at him he's
same age he's what I want to be
it's not fair it's just not fair yeah
they're crushing a good looking couple
he's got the he's got the blue shirt
brings out his blue eyes Big Joe
yeah it's got to be about your size Bob
oh yeah right boy he might be six three
is he six four might be taller than that
she's 34. oh very similar to you Brian
what's that he's 56 this girl's 34.
there you go he has so many similarities
six four all all six four two that's a
big kid
he's my he's one of my favorites growing
up damn he playing at West Covina hi
nachos man how did they not have a
street name after him Brandon will be in
West Covina and Covina next year in one
year so get your tickets probably or
would do you and me there that's what we
should do it's a great Club 100 I'll
text him after this it's such a good
club let's do it
do that sooner than later yeah be an
easy one to do
easy to do buddy yeah we're glad you got
into quarterback though give you a
little yeah
yeah and I didn't realize how how bad
how many hits they take I didn't realize
that game's different now though they
don't take as many still getting the win
knocked out I'm still getting pushed to
the ground so Ginge
yeah
who cares one time it's so much safer
now her cousin's on the ground he's like
ah ah he had to win I got him and that
giant dude is just he's just kind of
sitting like this looking off like that
and then he goes you'll be all right
let's ask him
yeah no thanks yeah I wonder it's I'm
surprised Patrick Mahomes gave him all
that access talking about the best
player in the NFL I was like he can
follow me around but we've never seen
that yeah it's true no one does he's got
two cameras following you all the time
all times
and then you forget they're there
actually after a while you seem pretty
good or not but I'm sure they have all
rights so how many episodes are I'm only
three I don't know how many how many
episodes is it Jen what's it called
again quarterback on Netflix quarterback
I need a new show to watch man I
finished Game of Thrones for the third
yeah I said I watched uh Ted lasso first
season
uh there's something I just can't I I
can't get into the still I don't want a
silly show I like murder like mystery
horror same way you know what I did see
it hates too much not too much I like
nuts and you've always love nuts dude
listen I people like stand up if you
like stand up come to the Blue Room this
weekend in in Springfield the 100 year
old uh Willie's gonna perform with you
but people wonder why my skin looks the
way it does they wonder why I have
energy all day long does some of it have
to do with the fact that I eat macadamia
nuts every day I don't know but I eat
macadamia nuts every day and I know
they're the rarest not the most
expensive but House of macadamia makes
it very possible and affordable for me
to do so you tell me the house of Mac
Davis have made macadamia nuts not just
for the elite Rich dude not only that
dude not only that as many carbs as
cashews or almonds okay that they have
the best fat profile but how do they get
the price so low that I can eat them 90
plus Farmers they're vertically
integrated you idiot any more dumb
questions how about I slap you in the
mouth yeah but I'll tell you what how
about I put a bunch of macadamia nuts in
your mouth now I slap your mouth for
good measure okay can I if you do it can
you put them uh covered in chocolate
though yes I'll put them in chocolate
you take a slap to the mouth with all
your chocolatey white chocolate you want
dark you want milk chocolate what do you
want I got everything dude I want a
creamy Nut Butter all right nut Butters
are so good man dude you got if you have
a Macadamia bar I'm gonna freak out dude
you're making 45 Macadamia snack bars I
got I got macadamia nut I go what are
they filled with all sorts of sugar
virgin Macadamia Oil which I only cook
but now it sounds tasty but they're
filled with all sorts of sugar no
there's no sugar bro I got blueberry I
got coconut I got white chocolate I got
plain chocolate dude if you're gonna
give me an audience a free box of 45 Mac
demons one of each flavor I'm gonna bust
I'm gonna do that how about this for a
limited time we're gifting a free box of
45 a minute so when in other words the
snack bars have 45 pure macadamia nut
one of each flavor when you visit House
of
macadamias.com
t-f-a-k House of macadam damias.com
plus we're gonna give you 20 off your
entire order
I'm the nut claws man you a nut club I'm
a Nut on you I'm a nut club who you what
yeah yeah
no with my macadamias oh okay I'm Gonna
Make It Rain on your face okay let's
throw a bunch of nuts in my mouth but
your nose holds a bunch of nuts my nose
only one way to find out
so creepy not too much uh you know what
I did see four is good was um I saw uh
Killer Robots on on Netflix now I'm out
oh dude no I don't like it AI so this
scared me though because these two
scientists said let's put in chat gbt or
AI let's see if they can come up with
different concoctions for chemical
weapons
and the artificial I think Chad DPT
writer came out with forty thousand
forty thousand different chemical
weapons and they all worked and the
White House got a hold of it and the
White House brought them to their thing
and said hey what do we do about this
and they were like we don't know anybody
can access it well they are accessing it
and now there's a race there's an AI
race and they tried to have a global
pause they were like listen if we don't
have Elon said you're going to have
autonomous robots that don't need a
human to kill and by the way there's
already this AI arms race because the AI
is going to crush anybody who's not
correct so America and China were like
and Russia were like no we're not doing
that because I don't trust you that's
that's why uh Elon and um fetterman were
like can we put a pause on this in
Zuckerberg can we have a six months but
the criminals at the dark side's like no
stop China and Russia you think they're
going to stop and no also also um with
Gene editing where you can mess with
viruses and stuff it's like no we're
fine
uh yeah it's all scary what do you do
about it nothing well you know what I'm
talking about you know what I thought
about what if AI can come up with ways
to create it ai's AI can also come up
with ways to neutralize it and destroy
it so like I have this thought that I
wonder if it just becomes this battle
within AI where it's like fighting it's
neutralized yeah evil
but then it's like if you keep
extrapolating it's a Race So even
computers have a race of Good and Evil
yeah but it's all based off who's
who's controlling it
yeah but like I don't know it's hard not
to think about in a spiritual Dimension
like it's hard not to think that who
what is going on like what are we
creating our own Gods our own our own
decisions God's all-knowing right that's
AI yeah and and then where does it go
have you ever messed with chat gbt or AI
I have did you type in should I wear
sandals with jeans what'd you say
have you done that it it said flip-flops
if they're very expensive is okay are
okay if it's if my God says something
different really yeah it said that
you're a little too lazy to put to to
kind of put your foot in a prison and
choose to feel like a prison lately
yeah and why wear pants do they make you
mad a little bit no my chat GB said
didn't say anything oh it didn't okay
instead of if you're at a gay pride
event fire away wear your sandals yeah
but in all other situations especially
airport and Studio I don't do it anymore
I don't know airports no no thank you no
airports that's Chad GPD I said am I gay
if I watch a girl on girl porn I said
absolutely so again okay my God's
different yeah your gods are different
and your chat GPT will tell you
different things huh interesting all
right did chat what is it about having
uh those those laces on top of the other
laces to make sure everything is okay
yeah dude my chat gbt I typed that and
said lit really because you need those
laces to keep the others getting crazy
no it's climb rope oh so if you were
driving I take that out
so in other words in case your feet your
shoes fly off your feet no I could just
when I like let's say someone came in
right out on lace this huh kill you
they're called mission impossible oh so
you can grow something yeah yeah kill
you
oh okay I don't know dude throw it over
them
tie them up fashion point is I need a
new show I started watching American
Horror Story for the third time season
one good I think it's the greatest TV
series of all time really 11 Seasons
dude and they're all [__] fire
American Horror Story the first season
was unbelievable oh dude I never saw it
after that oh really there's better most
fancy season one's the best at the
season one the house is great the
Covenant is great the asylum's great
that season twos might be the best
season the the cult one's great where
it's super
um political this cult leader he's like
super pro Trump it's so good that one's
great
um the last one's great in New York with
the gay killer they they're they're all
to be that long that what's it Murphy
doesn't Ryan Murphy he's a genius my God
Ryan Murphy did Glee and Ryan Murphy
knows his serial coach because if you
know serial killers like the boy he puts
subtle hints in all of it like the
Richard Ramirez Charles Manson did you
see that who they caught the New York
architect did I call it tell you oh the
guy in Long Island yeah see what he
looks like yeah he's a giant big dude
and he owns a Consulting and
Architecture Firm I remember this I
remember when they knew he called you
say Gilgo Gilgo yeah he called the he
called the the woman he killed he called
her sister and taunted her on a burner
phone because he's the same he had a
bunch of burner phones yeah they caught
him
they caught him because they found his
hair and his sisters and wives his
wife's hair but they caught and then
they saved that DNA from you know you're
talking about two and four I think okay
and they saved the DNA from that hair
that they found the scene and then they
thought he was a suspect this fat [__]
was eating pizza and left DNA on the
pizza so they crossed pollinated the
pizza with the strings of hair boom it's
FBI for you but they've been looking for
this guy because this was 10 this is 15
years ago I remember it and they were
finding parts of bodies 10 10 body part
10 bodies that they found but they he
they only have him on four right now but
they think it's up they found like a
female toddler yeah an Asian man most of
them are all uh escorts
yeah he's a sadist he they found um he
got away with it also you know no sir
most serial killers stop after 50
because they're too old and you know
their bodies
he was 51 when his last murder they said
but then they said it's unheard of for
sale here to be older and 51. really
yeah you're too old
you see how big he is compared to
everybody I was like is he a giant oh
basically like John Wayne Gacy John
Wayne Gacy was big bring him up with all
these law enforcement I'll tell you
right now ain't nobody ain't nobody
compared to Ed camper The Co-Ed Killer
six nine daddy oh and had the IQ of
Albert Einstein look at his face look at
the close look at how big he is there
just Tower they said he towered over
everybody
I wonder how big he is he's they say
he's he's not Edge I said when I met him
his hand was so big but he ate that
camper he's pretty big dude act number
six nine brother that's a big boy three
340. look at his evil face like look at
this look at that look at how much look
at him
what's weird is he had kids and [__] oh
yeah family man oh yeah wife he would do
it when his wife would leave six four
he's one he's way more than 240. yeah so
he's 6'4 yeah eight Kemper six eight six
nine
that's strange so you got away with it
for a hot second evil but that's but
that's how these serial killers get away
with it like the BTK killer like he was
at the church he was a church goer
family man so no one suspects it but the
the FBI agents that retired now they
called this they said you guys are
looking in the wrong place this is a
family man who can blend in so he didn't
get caught damn he's doing normal stuff
you gotta look around the neighborhoods
because he had a Colorado Avalanche and
one of The Pimps where his girl was
murdered by this guy the pimp goes I saw
a Colorado Avalanche uh you know the the
GMC Avalanches Chevy Avalanches I saw
one of those at them that took the girl
away it's a Chevy Avalanche so that's
how they found him wow because he parked
his avalanche on the side of the street
like well who's is that wow and they
started looking into him but apparently
they've been focused on him for like
eight weeks oh yeah until they got the
DNA from the cross so they watched him
actually since 2022. they've been
watching them they've been studying him
and they they were collecting DNA
evidence models and stuff so they got
them they'd go through his trash and
pick and get evidence and then go from
there so I didn't heard of him before
this no but I remember I remember that I
I remember thinking this guy is so awful
because he was a sadist I'd read a book
about the worst of the serial killers
because he had they found torture porn
on us on us nobody wears some BTK but
but this guy that this guy was um like
he he called the sister of one of the
victims and taunted her and that's a
sadist that's a guy who gets off on like
putting people through pain yeah so I
remember thinking I hope they catch this
scumbag dude speaking of circulars how
about the home girl from The Charles
Manson got out I know Newsome would
always appeal and not let her out and
then she she spent 50 years in prison 53
53 years in prison here's my only caveat
with this I think she went in when she
was 18 or 16. she was 16. she's a very
different person yeah she's a very
different person
she was the youngest one yeah she's a
different human being boy Manson like
dude he his his brothel women were not
tens let me let me go back to those
women Bunch twos make a six would get a
little self-respect well they were they
were they were young boys on the left of
the mustache gals he had one with them
on the left mustache and shoes they
actually commit all the murders is that
what they those uh the girl who so I'll
tell you right now so the girl on the
right who got shot out she never
murdered anybody she was there and she
didn't go to the police but she did the
LA Bianca murders in uh in I think it
was It Felix
the Tate house I think no it's not
completely understand no no no no no she
did kill people she didn't what she did
is after Tex Watson stabbed the woman he
goes you gotta do something so she took
a knife and stabbed it she was already
dead stabbed it eight times in the back
she was already dead though she's so she
never officially murdered anybody but
she did stab a dead body
um but then here it says uh she she
admitted saying that she stabbed it 16
times in the lower back and then I went
to like the Wikipedia oh I'll go back to
that please yeah but she was already
dead yeah that's that's what's kind of
that's why I'm saying she never killed
anybody
might as well though I mean because who
knows
those Lobby on cameras are awful man is
a wife and husband horrible and they
just went in and killed the husband the
the wife heard it and then it's bad
yeah bad bad she stabbed her 16 times in
the lower back when she was already dead
though it looks like she was she was
still calling for uh horrible she was
like 18.
yeah
Los Feliz that's not even close to where
the Sharon Tate's in Beverly Hills gym
you know more about this now oh yeah I
got my black belt in this [__]
I'm too weird about it
so where are the other Killers they're
all still in jail the the Tex Watson and
he's in a prison in uh Texas he's wrote
in several books about it and the other
two I think are dead yeah those two are
dead from cancer almost everyone's died
of cancer oh really yeah Charles Manson
died of cancer the two women who died in
prison she's the only one that's left
yeah how old is she 70 something
which is 53 years she went in when she
was 16. is that right 18.
look at that one she's the youngest one
oh when she was 19.
what a life and now she's a different
person
73. yeah you can see her how how like
she's a different person let me ask this
be what you have around the podcast
uh I don't know it's very sad it's the
whole thing is sad talk about the most
famous murder in American history which
I don't think it deserves that just
because it involves Sharon Tate it's the
biggest
you gotta you gotta you can't move on
unless you forgive after that after all
that time it's like it's over it's over
it's over 53 years long times a lifetime
so Sharon Tate's sister was on Nightline
and gave a few talking points here or
give me a few statements well I pray
until I was growing my teeth and every
kiss every smile every pledge reaction I
have
oh wow yeah it's dark yeah it's terrible
but
super dark it's over man she's also 19
you know and easily influenced yes
Manson always pick on the people that
had no idea the person that you're
seeing there is a very different person
literally a different person maybe
literally maybe I think so I think you
change I think there's 73 yeah there you
don't know we don't know their Central
is bad that's a person who was just so
probably dumb and brainwashed and
um you know listen I'm a far cry from
Elon Musk but at 19 you you couldn't
convince me to stab someone 19 times
yeah even if they're dead yeah and then
she wrote into the body and then took
blood and wrote pigs on the wall and
helped her Skelter because Matt said
make it witchy is it possible though
sometimes that people like gang members
who do some terrible [__] then they're
45 and they're just a different dude you
know there's a lot of that right you you
you I don't think there's a lot of that
I don't know that's what's wrong with
prison
no there is I think you're a different
person not only comes to murder I don't
think so
um if you're able to do something that
dark now I don't know so she was a model
Citizen and you know there's but one of
the things that they say is like the
reason we we recruit 18 year olds is
because you can get 18 year olds to
believe in a lot of stuff and the way
you get an army to March and kill is not
through you get them to and it's been
written about a lot that's why
propaganda is very powerful you get them
to march Under symbols and under slogans
yeah meaning and you teach them that the
enemy is
if by killing the enemy the world's a
better place I mean that's what happened
with the Japanese yeah all that it
happened the Japanese soldiers yeah
Nazis so young Nazis with Jews men yeah
young men do terrible things and when
they get older and they get perspective
on the world they go oh my God I know so
I think there's a lot of that and I
think that um you know when you're 19
and you're and you've had time 53 years
to reflect now now a serial killer who
was killing a lot of people and got off
on it they should be killed they should
be killed pedophiles there's no colors
if you're 53 you can't go out you're
just a kid I don't know because that's
that's something that's in them and I
agree to me you are sick and you didn't
get better you're just waiting yeah I
agree with this kind of stuff it's like
you can see why they let her out it's
like yeah here's the other thing she's
out 79 yeah what's she gonna do even
let's say she was still that demon and
once a Kill Bill 79 well you know they
let that guy out of chop that woman's
arms off yes and then he raped her and
oh guess what he was in the 70s and
guess what he did it again yeah what a
surprise guy's different right yeah I
know the whole gen you know no no no gun
give me gun yeah give me a gun you did
that crime I'm I'm gonna shoot you like
I don't want you to be in jail we just
got to get rid of you perfect spicy too
because of good behavior you know you're
gonna get out earlier than you're
supposed to so it's like John Wayne Gacy
he was in uh prison he went to prison
for less than a young man he was in
prison and he was supposed to do like
eight years but he got out I think in a
year or two for good behavior yeah he
knew he'd get out and then do it again
so there's it's always it's nice yeah
it's tough I want to make that decision
dude if you molest if you're an adult
and you have like engaged in child rape
or something we gotta kill you we you
gotta go you gotta go taxpayers
shouldn't be paid now maybe in 20 years
they'll be able to do something to your
brain where you don't remember it you're
not that person anymore okay but until
then I you gotta go yeah I agree
go
[Music]
go ahead and give me start starts to
tell me what he did and then just start
maybe saying well we could censor him go
ahead and watch watch this Vinnie stitch
on his stuff yeah man yeah
no but just hear me out Vinnie says that
he gave him some information to help us
out give us some time but did he snitch
yeah he's gotta go okay and your
nickname's got to go count gotta go yeah
they call me we gotta go Gotta Go I
gotta go talk to gotta go that's my
nickname gotta go They're gonna say now
if you go to gallery
they're gonna go They're gonna go now
you don't want to go to gotta go count
because he's gonna you know he's gonna
say you gotta go go to did you have fun
Brandon though
George listen what's up Brandon you know
I love him he's a Marine
he does what I tell him but he's not
enforcing the law he's not and that
makes me look bad
and all he keeps asking is did you have
fun though what I have to do what do you
got to do he's got to go Gotta Go
calling
It's gotta go he's gotta go all I'm
saying I'd be more of a fun mom guy now
in court I'm arrested now you're the
judge say did they call you got to go
I'll say sir we have on record that your
nickname has gotta go very active
bladder your honor
and uh an explosive diarrhea
and bananas
and judge would let me go go did you
have fun though you know I kind of did
as many people as I killed that the
worst Mafia enforcers can do it I'm
talking to Sammy the bull Sammy the
Bulls like I nothing had just sociopath
I wouldn't kill anything yeah shot his
brother-in-law in the back of the head
yeah sociopath what do you got Jen
all right
the first one I thought was pretty crazy
so kid his head was decapitated I saw
this and I didn't even look into him
like what the [__] happened yeah so
decapitated as in the spinal whatever
that bone the base of the skull to the
your spinal bone it got detached but the
ligaments the all the you know the veins
and all the stuff
the blood supply it was still there but
the head was detached from the kid
because he got hit by a car and then
these he got flown into a hospital and
the doctors were able this is internally
decapitated but inside like the neck the
skin everything was still especially
your kids flopping over from the bone
yeah
oh that's him there that's him right
here in the middle and the two doctors
have fixed them
oh my God that's impressive yeah those
doctors Jesus guys right on the left
Jesus Christ thank goodness it's that
big oh my God you guys don't figure out
everything internally decapitated yeah
and it shows like a diagram right here
so just at the base it's separated yeah
wow that's interesting
thank God for Western medicine they say
75 or more people that this happens to
they die like before they get to the
hospital of course so because the
internal bleeding all the critical
everything yeah your head's off your
head's yeah your head fell off they say
cutting your head off is painless
who says that
uh right well the guillotine would come
down and cut your head off and oh yeah
the mouth the mouth would be prayers
who'd you interview that's like when
they go sharks don't like taste humans
really what shark told you that yeah
really well
I would imagine it's got to hurt a
little bit although the brain can live
without
five minutes so you're still rolling
around looking you might be able to see
her about it your own body right
medieval times when they cut your head
off and you're just rolling around
looking well they the mouth would still
be mouthing prayers or saying stuff like
oh my God
yep
interesting
but you know when you get choked out
you're out so when you get your head
chopped off you're probably out
you go right out
you don't know they get knocked out yeah
maybe yeah hopefully you're right yeah I
don't think any answers are going to go
by medieval [__] guilty led to the uh
Jesus I don't want to get my head but
then
yeah I mean the choke out there's no
real pain it's just like you know but
that's your no it's so fast like your
body can't yeah I don't know it's like I
was watching this Tick Tock or Instagram
influencer and you know crazy rush or
some [__] like that she was hot she's
like hey the car's like whoa no no no
dude
awful way to go she's all whoo dues 45
miles an hour
so she died I'm dead yeah you gotta go
got him you gotta go I was on Tick Tock
or what I don't know one of those things
but it made Worldstar
it made Worldstar all right poor girl
but also don't hang out at cars like 45
miles an hour I'll tell you don't do
that but then you just boom oh dude
she's like yeah
boom and then it goes black what a way
to die
don't for the gram baby
what did she hit who knows uh light post
oh well that's those they're not
forgiving they're not yeah all right
Postman what happened
what was that
yeah you can't stick your [__] head
out the window uh her whole body's out
too so it's like I can't do that it's
like my friend we were 60 miles an hour
my idiot friend goes out on the he's on
the windshield on the highway
he's on the windshield holding my ah
we're all laughing Terminator two huh
like the guy in Terminator too that's
not good it's not good that's not far
I'm old so I get very nervous what else
you got you in you see how that video
that cop that was hanging onto a
windshield and the guy just took off
and he had the gun in front of the
windshield but the car took off super
fast did you shoot him no he kept saying
turn off the garage and the guy just
zooms past hey never got any shots off
no you gotta you gotta get your shots
off you can get shots up and the guy hit
a bump and then it flew off and then he
the cop even told the cops that were
following him just get him I'm fine I'm
fine but then he had a broken back when
he went to the hospital damn broken back
yeah you don't realize like even going
20 miles an hour and you hit your head
you're [__] so if you're in a car and
you drive toward a cop when he tells you
to stop that's you're allowed to shoot
him right in the face that's a give I
know I'm sure he could have but he
didn't want to do it we probably didn't
want to lose his job
yeah the video has just been released in
L.A they let him go you gotta shoot him
now in L.A he got recruited he's now
head of the LAPD yep
Jesus Christ yeah that's just a good cop
he didn't want to take the guy's life
bro that's crazy this guy was on a drift
for two months fishing gear with his
daughter always spring fishing gear lost
weight though this is the real Cast Away
the Castaway I think he was gone for
like years he said it was just like
Castaway and he looked like him too yeah
but this is after two months two months
he had a tiny boat too by the way you're
out in the middle of the Pacific and
they found him and that's how big the
Pacific is he survived off of raw fish
and rainwater him and his dog they both
survived raw fish and rainwater good you
think and then Tom Hanks called him
check out the apparently he's really
healthy that's his boat great yeah
his beard uh is is probably super clean
least of his words yeah
bro I uh we we always have because hot
out so we have you know we live in the
valley we have the lizards around the
pool there's chilling yeah my son
catches one cute looking lizard this
thing I'll give it to him this thing was
cute his dad came and keep him I go sure
why not the lizards need more friends
let's toss them in I can't run into this
okay let's toss them in there he'll have
fun because he's just gonna die out here
from a bird or the weather sure but
don't swim in there my big beardy dragon
he's big now he's thick he's like this
long I'm like a [__] big the big
birdie Dragon what who's the new kid I
mean he's your friend oh you toss him in
with beer I toss him with the beardies I
have three beardies oh no the beard he
goes who's the new kid that's your
friend be nice he went he gotta go
dude my son that sounds like look
they're friends they're nose to nose I'm
like look they're kissing
yeah and eat quick
swell him right there goes Daddy I'm
like oh my God that thing is [__] oh
boy and I have to Google I'm like the
beard dragons eat other lizards well
they sure do yeah they do they're
smaller yeah they sure do
that's why you don't take a baby polar
bear and put it in with other polar
bears because polar bears in the zoo go
I'm gonna eat that baby that's polar
bear right we're talking about lizards
here same thing I didn't know they'd get
down like that he's oh and then my son
goes they just do the same [__] then my
son goes maybe it was just that one they
didn't get along so he catches another
one and we'll see how it goes dude I got
the [__] Ted Bundy of beard dragons
we toss them in there he goes the [__]
honk yeah I'm like oh this is inside he
does he's not lonely he'll just do it oh
no no no you're hungry he's fat I'll
take a picture he's fat so my koi
remember how they all got decimated and
killed guess what I think they one of
them laid eggs because there's a bunch
more in there just one one oh just one
hiding hiding alone and I googled koi
get lonely so I'm going to buy some more
koi
yeah I like a koi you know you could put
a well you have to buy a heater that's a
lot of work for you but if you heat it
that bad boy up you could put a big
arowana in there
when I yeah raccoons
yeah really oh no they eat monkeys bro
they're called jumping monkey fish
how small it's too small for that but
tell me how small what are you talking
about here it's like a little little
Pond little a little like size of this
carpet yeah that's good for arowana
we'll go back and forth in circles yeah
um
my friend my friend uh one time we got
in the pool and my friend goes ah scream
and jumped what is it what is it huh and
I was like he grew up in the city you
know what it was a baby bunny
damn at the bottom of the pool no it was
alive and it was it got stuck and I and
I saved it I go it's a [__] baby
bunny ah what is it city slicker City
Slicker and a half yeah Jesus
point is uh don't toss random lizards in
with your bearded dude there's a video
on Nature's metal where a duck is
getting taken out by ah Turtle sometimes
Turtles go I'm gonna eat that duck and
they do yeah if they're hungry enough oh
yeah if they're hungry enough
like a snapping turtle ah well horses
there's that video of that horse you see
that video of that horse
[__] that dude up and when I say [__]
and I do that the horse is over him
grabbing it in his mouth and shaking
though the guy must done something
because horses the horse is like I've
had enough of you wasn't the donkey no
that's a donkey donkeys will do that
yeah this is a large horse I can't think
of any more terrified and you go oh my
God yeah but it was a guy hitting and
stuff because they just don't there's
something going on it might have been a
stallion he might try to [__] it a lot
of people do that no I know what you had
on this you see Mr hands well let look
this up horse bites chin bring up Mr
hands attack man no do you like to watch
Mr hands once a month
um no this is where the horse is over
him and shaking him you might want to
just go horse attacks man hey you know
what's crazy is on that Mr hands video
you know the video we watch where the
guy goes right there dude top you know
that's not the video that killed him
that's not the horse that killed him it
was after that watch this watch this wow
good for the horse man yeah man get get
up on that tree too
angry horses yikes horses stupid man
well they're stupid but that thing ain't
messing around he must have hurt the
horse tried sleeping with it maybe maybe
the horses fighting me today what you're
not riding me today horses scare me what
were you gonna say yeah I'm saying with
Mr hands video back to Mr hands the
video we watch videos that you know that
that was just a good time for him that
didn't kill him he died after the fact
he went back in and they don't have that
footage he went back in for him he went
back in yeah for round two yeah yeah no
I think he went to a party didn't get
help and then no but that video is not
from that that was the time with a horse
really no that was just a good time
really yeah news to me dude good Lord Mr
hands I don't know what to say about any
of that dude
real freak yeah what else you got Jen
um so this someone found I guess this is
a doctor or something he found an
internal memo with the in and out
Executives and there's no more masks
they're saying that it's actually a it's
a mandate you cannot wear a mask unless
you have a doctor's note thank God but I
mean like if they want to wear a mask ah
bro but they said America so that's kind
of going against you know and
Chick-fil-A and if they don't do it and
it's opposite so it shows the numbers of
in and out in Chick-fil-A in and out
goes no Mass Master illegal Chick-fil-A
goes we want mask sales
so they could get terminated if they
don't do this love it I don't think they
should be able to get fired their own it
is America should be whatever you want
they want yeah yeah let them do whatever
they want but I'm within and out like
hey hey [__] not everyone needs to
wear a mask
but they want them to see the smiles and
everything so that's the molecular
biologist named Dr lucky Tran yeah that
makes sense
yeah unless you have a medical but like
hey we need Smiles we don't want this
weird creepy mask that reminds people
that we're in a dictatorship for a
little bit man impersonates TSA agents
have different airports and totally epic
performance that's funny keep going Jen
what else you got um hold on one sec
this one okay
I was looking into this since what July
16th oh my God yesterday so apparently
this woman uh she saw she saw a toddler
on the side of a freeway she stopped her
car and then she suddenly disappeared
after that she called her sister and I
think she called 911 as well aliens
but then she suddenly got returned home
like two days later
and it's always hold on before you
finish the story
look at how skeptical my eyes are I know
I smell yeah I smell [__]
so apparently she was distraught didn't
talk there's no in the police were going
to investigate it after you know after
she kind of calms down from this thing
but it's very weird so the mo the most
recent thing I heard so far was there
was a
sort of a GoFundMe type of thing that
happened for the missing persons if you
could find her and it went up to like 68
000 and her boyfriend said oh yeah she
was kidnapped but she hasn't really said
she was kidnapped yet
you guys following yeah something's up
something's up something something's
definitely up yeah is there a horse
involved yeah it sounds like some kind I
think the more the more time passes by
it seems as though they probably planned
this to get money I don't know although
there was an Instagram thing where a
child clearly had Down syndrome really
cute little child was walking towards
him like that and on the highway and he
goes what is going on here it stopped
his car and I I think the kid got out
you know what I mean yeah yeah
wanna have fun I don't know yeah
my leg's been sore that's all my leg's
been a little sore I like to tell shitty
stories
you start touching my legs
hey man this is your big gay friend
no you got a big tongue yeah thank you
both anything
this is the last one
yep sure do
this happened in July but not recent not
super recently early July but I thought
it was worth showing this uh this
weatherman he was in sort of a fender
bender it's a road rage thing and this
guy walks up and by the way it's the
other guy's fault so which one's the
weather man the one dressed like a dork
yes
Avery tomasco it still seems a little
shaken up by this
he got completely missed this guy looks
like boxes
boy whipped that's what I used
you hit my blank car and I replied no
you hit my car look at this
okay look at this what happened dude is
that Floyd Mayweather what do you guys
think who's falter who's that fault here
who's in the car up above the Prius has
got to hit him I slam on the horn hit
the brakes but it's unfortunately too
late at that point even the bar coming
into my lane I slam well it's clearly
the prius's fault but the guy could have
the guy could have slowed down I was
driving a Prius yeah with the ponytail
he looks kind of Asian too yes right
with your hair didn't look kind of Asian
he looked Asian that guy was Asian bro
was he straight up Asian yeah I'd say
that's pretty Asian muscular strong
looking Asian guy boy did boy did he
whip I'm more forget all right he's
Asian give me all the felonies you want
but this punch is what I'm worried about
you missed the meteorologist
like this whoop I think I went anyways
so
well what he did was he did he went like
that first and the guy just went anyway
dude you hit my car it would have been
better if he slipped boom and came right
back everybody neurologist lit him up
and that's what he looks like now
he's changed I had a total makeover but
that's it that's all the current events
we had yeah yeah all right man well well
guys uh do you have fun do you have fun
though do you have fun though that's the
name of the new tour Jeff fun though
July 28th job and Friends Pasadena Ice
House one show Friday night July 29th we
have uh Kyle bass's fight companion uh
with Cheeto Vera and some very funny
friends yeah I love Cheeto that shopping
friends of Pasadena Ice House July 28th
I think it's an 8pm show uh once you
only then Phoenix Arizona stand-up live
two shows Friday August 11th in Phoenix
I'll be at JT's Wings most of the time
anyways because I'm fat oh uh Oma almost
said Ohio Omaha Nebraska one night only
August 16th Kansas City one night only
August 17th I'll be having barbecue at
both spots Liberty Township Ohio's
August 30th Columbus Ohio August 31st
Spokane Washington September 21st
through the 23rd all right love you guys
Missouri this
huh Willie's Willy I mean you have to
have them open yeah I could he's 100 no
I'm bringing my my feature but you have
to have them Willy yeah you get this oh
no he won't listen because he's a
hundred okay legit 100 years old but he
opens for everybody there for Nick
Swartz in me he's the best all right
prayer Griffin he's a hundred great oh
there we are there I am look at that
cute you're gonna love that City dude oh
I like that the new the new look on the
uh podcast let me see my website Improv
Ontario July 27 28 29. oh man look at
how that's great look before my eye
before my eye surgery look at that right
there you guys wonder why I got eye
surgery holy [__] never have look at
that podcast look at us the two of us
young young guys young couple young cats
no gram my beard wow man tears
all right kids love you that's it wait
go back to that see you Wednesday I
admit it we got Bill Bill Bellamy on
Wednesday
uh what's that
okay
Angelus cordos thanks buddy I don't know
who that is I didn't do this I'm loving
my new website I gotta hey man figure it
on your own sorry bro I gotta go so you
guys love you sorry man